So go ahead and update the query conferences function to
use filters. This time make sure you're editing the query
conferences method. Not the playground method that you were using
before. So things you're going to need to do. You're going to
need to get the conference query form out of the
Lesson 4 folder, and put it in the form package
of your project. You're going to need to update the
signature of query conferences and conference API. To take an input
parameter of conferenceQueryForm, and
then just Call conferenceQueryForm.getQuery
to actually run the query. And then optionally, if
you want the optimization to pre-load the organizers' profile
entities. So what are some of the things that
you need to be aware of? We're including a
UI like the show conferences page, that let's users
add multiple filters in any order. You have to
consider whether the deployed app has to have composite
indexes for every filter combination. You have to think about
the fact that multiple filters per query, increase the data
store rights. And you need to think about whether multiple
index entries take up more space in the data store.